how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and yesterday's
episode of one division was
fantastic it was the best episode that
we've gotten so far
and one thing that it did give us subtly
throughout the entire
episode not just at the end is give us
clues to who that secret cameo that paul
bettany has been talking about could
actually be now if you have not seen
episode 5 of one division
and i suppose all of the episodes before
that there are going to be spoilers for
those episodes
in this video so if you're trying to
avoid any and all spoilers for one
vision up to episode 5 you should click
away now
but if you love marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos
so recently as i'm sure most of you know
paul bettany was interviewed where he
talked about
a surprise secret cameo coming towards
the end of one division
i think people would be really excited
i've always wanted to work
uh with this guy and
it's pretty the scenes are pretty
intense
now this combined with elizabeth olsen
saying something about a surprise cameo
as well
has made the internet go crazy and
trying to figure out who exactly the
secret cameo is going to be from and
what character is it going to be
but after the last episode of one
division there seems to be clues on who
exactly this is going to be and we may
have figured this out now in my original
video on who i thought this would be
i said that it could be toby maguire
spider-man and of course it still could
be
but i also believe that in episode 5
marvel gave us subtle hints that it
could
actually be magneto and this makes a lot
of sense when you break it down which of
course i will
spoilers for the mandalorian season 2
finale coming up if you have not seen it
recently somebody asked elizabeth olson
if there is a luke skywalker mandalorian
size
appearance coming in one division and
her response was
yes so that means whoever this cameo is
that both elizabeth olsen and paul
bettany are talking about
is a really really big cameo and luke
skywalker was somebody that was from the
original star wars films
which leads many people to believe
including myself that they're going to
bring an
old marvel actor back to reprise a role
and now
after one division episode 5 where they
brought back quicksilver
not aaron taylor johnson's quicksilver
but evan peters quicksilver from the
other marvel x-men universe anything is
freaking possible with marvel
but let's dissect a few parts of the
last episode of wanda vision
now for those of you who may not know at
one point in time in the comics magneto
was retconned to be
the father of quicksilver and the
scarlet witch
so wanda and pietro's father was magneto
specifically he was their father during
the house of
m story which we already know is a heavy
influence on what we're seeing
in one division now what's really
interesting about this is that in the
house of m storyline
quicksilver dies but wanda resurrects
him she brings him back to life
and she does this by warping reality
something that we are seeing
right now in one division and it does
look like she revived her brother
in this alternate reality now i kind of
think he's evil and think maybe she
didn't actually revive him but still
he's revived which goes along with the
house of m storyline now of course the
biggest part of quicksilver appearing at
the end of one division episode 5
is that it's not aaron taylor johnson's
quicksilver who is the mcu
quicksilver that we saw on avengers age
of ultron it's evan peters's quicksilver
from the fox universe from the x-men
movies
now this was insanely awesome but it has
a lot of fans wondering exactly what the
heck is going on
is he actually quicksilver from that
x-men universe we know that one division
leads up to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and the multiverse
is going to be a huge factor moving
forward now as far as magneto was
concerned the fact that they resurrected
this quicksilver
actually makes a lot of sense because in
the fox universe in the x-men films
this quicksilver finds out that magneto
is his father
so that's the route that fox went they
went the route of magneto
being the father of wanda and pietro and
now seemingly
that quicksilver whose father was
magneto is in the mcu
and is the brother of r wanda could they
be doing a type of retcon to where
wanda is the daughter of magneto kevin
feige has officially announced that the
mutants are coming to the mcu
and technically quicksilver is the first
mutant to enter the mcu
but it wouldn't be surprising if mutants
started to show up randomly
now in this episode of one division it
did reveal who their parents were it
said their names but that happens in the
comics too
they believed their parents to be the
maximoffs but in reality magneto was
their father
so that could be the same thing in one
division and if you look closely at some
scenes there are a lot of resemblances
between the x-men and one division and
wanda and
magneto in the epic scene where wanda
walks out of her reality with the drone
and throws it back at sword
wanda would soon after turn all the
sword agents on tyler hayward
right before she does this she says i'm
not the one with the guns
this seems to be a mirror scene from the
original x-men film in 2000 where
magneto used his ability to control
metal to turn the soldiers guns against
themselves
as he drops the line you homo sapiens
and your guns and that was sir ian
mckellen's magneto
but it also mirrors a scene from michael
fassbender's magneto from 2019's dark
phoenix the scene on the train where he
uses his powers to take control of the
weaponry on board the train
but perhaps the most direct connection
between wanda and magneto comes at the
end
where wanda releases everybody from her
powers as she turns and walks away she
flicks her hand into the air and
releases
all the sword agents from her powers
this looks exactly like magneto does
in dark phoenix where he releases people
from his powers where he turns flicks
his wrist and walks away
could these similarities be because
magneto is the father of wanda
and petro in the mcu is this the
direction that marvel is going to go
down
well it's been speculated for a very
long time that one division was going to
introduce mutants to the mcu
which they technically did but will they
take it even further by introducing
magneto
specifically ian mckellen's magneto
because again if we're talking about
this cameo that paul bettany is super
excited to work about and somebody
that's on technically a luke skywalker
level cameo it's probably one of the
original marvel actors from one of the
original movies but if you recall we
actually have proof that kevin feige was
reaching out to some of the original
actors from the x-men
patrick stewart revealed about a year
ago that kevin feige reached out to him
called him into the studio for a meeting
and they had a talk
now according to patrick stewart what
they were talking about was professor
xavier in the marvel cinematic universe
and the future for him now patrick
stewart did say
that he was not going to come back to
reprise his role he said that he said
goodbye to his role
of professor charles xavier and logan
when he died he said maybe if he hadn't
had said goodbye in that show he could
have still come back
but the multiverse in the marvel
cinematic universe is now a thing as we
saw
at the end of episode 5 of one division
and now people like patrick stewart and
ian mckellen can come for a quick cameo
and not have to commit to years and
years of playing the same character
they would only have to commit to about
one or two days of filming if it's a
quick cameo now i personally would
assume that since kevin feige met with
patrick stewart that he probably met
with ian and callan as well but the
reason that we may not have heard about
it is because
ian mckellen might have said yes to
coming back as magneto because it works
very well with the story of one division
because you're not just going to come
back for the heck of it there has to be
a good reason
fan service is great but the story also
has to work and ian mckellen never said
that he would not return as magneto in
fact
in that universe magneto is still alive
and now the quick silver
from that universe the same universe as
magneto is in
our universe the mcu and that
quicksilver's father is magneto and his
sister
is wanda then we have all of the
similarities between wanda and the two
different versions of magneto from the
fox universe and this is why i
believe that it's ian mckellen that
could be showing up in one division as
magneto
as wanda's father i think story wise it
makes a lot of sense
it would of course offer some fan
service but it would also introduce the
x-men into the mcu and i think that the
last episode gave us some hints that it
could
happen but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe for more
theories and easter eggs about wanda
vision don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can always
follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof